okay so let's get started again the new
low bounce for general boolean circuits
don't come around that often and there
was one value recently by Sasha kulikov
and co-op with couple of whom are the
audience will be telling us what doesn't
relate to them in fact I'm not going to
tell a lot about this this new lower
bound instead I'm going to to present
you some some open some approaches that
could potentially lead to new improve
top lower bounds okay yeah first let me
fix the model I probably don't need to
do that but still let me just remind you
that we are dealing here with binary
boolean circuits with no restriction on
on the bases on the out degree on the
depths okay so there are three
well-known restricted circuit classes
the first one is obtained if we restrict
the bases namely the operation completed
at each gate to be I to be equalized at
two conjunction or disjunction in this
case we have monotone circuits another
thing that we might potentially restrict
it the depths of the circuit in this
case we we have constant depth circuits
for example algorithm their circuits and
the other thing that we can that we may
restrict is our degree of each gate and
in this case we get formulas so in this
case we have just the boolean binary
circuit and it is well it can be easily
seen that they can respond to straight
line programs right which is the
possibly the simplest the simplest
program for computing a boolean function
okay so of course the fundamental
question is for a given boolean function
what is the minimum number of gates or
what is the minimum number of lines in a
straight line program that computes this
function so more precisely we interested
not in a single function but usually
we're interested in a sequence of
functions one for every input size such
that that defines the language in NP and
that does not have a polynomial size
circuit so if we are able to construct
this then we would prove that p is not
equal to NP and it seems that we are
infinitely far from
in this goal okay so just if you count
the number of functions on them
variables which is 2 2 Z 2 to the M and
compare it to the number of seconds of
size less than 2 to the M divided by n
then you just get that there are not not
enough circuits to compute all these
functions and this was shown by Shannon
more than 70 or 80 years ago so I mean
by doing this we get this lower bound 2
to the N divided by n and it was proved
by Lupin F that that in fact the hidden
constant here can be shown can be shown
to be equal to 1 namely you can compute
any boolean function in size roughly 2
to the N 2 to the M divided by M without
even we go.okay
7 and this argument is of course
non-constructive so it doesn't give us
an explicit function which which has
exponential circuit size and by saying
explicit we usually mean a function from
NP but it differs in various paper so
sometimes well we don't even have a
function from e e to the NP for example
even from larger classes ok ok now let
me this is the outline of my talk so I
will start by by telling you some ideas
of the gate elimination method which is
essentially the only known method for
proving lower bounds for for
unrestricted seconds on one hand on the
other hand we do not expect this method
to give us lower bounds even not of size
5 mm or something not to say about
superlinear bombs and then I will
briefly review some of other approaches
that could potentially lead to improved
lower bounds ok so ok the question here
is how to prove for example a 3 and
lower bound for a boolean function f
this is usually done as follows by a
gate elimination method you first pick a
function which is resistant to
sufficiently many substitutions for
example F could be a purity function and
F is clearly resistant to n minus 1 bit
fixing substitutions meaning that after
any n minus 1 bit fixing substitutions
you have
function which is still not constant so
you need a circuit of some nonzero size
to compute this function and then you
show that basically for any for any
circuit computing app you you may you
can find a substitution that kills three
gates so by applying this process to
sample n minus one times you get a lower
bound three and minus three okay and
this is essentially the whole method so
the currently strongest lower bound
which we were able to get where it
recently is proved using this method the
corresponding function is is a kind of
parity but parity is resistant to be
tricks in substitutions and we need a
function which is resistant to affine
substitutions
okay so formally this is this is known
as an affine disperser for sub linear
dimension and it is defined as follows
it is non constant on any affine
subspace of the boolean Harbach
hypercube of light and half dimension
namely of dimension let let it be for
example square root of M okay so it is
it is highly non trivial to construct an
explicit such functions but but we in
our approach we use such a function as a
black box so once again it is a function
which is resistant to M minus square
root of n linear substitutions which
means that for us it is enough to show
that for any circuit we we can find an
affine substitutions the in a fine
substitution that kills slightly more
than three gates okay so this fancy this
3 plus 1 over 86 comes from the fact
that we use some same tricky complexity
measure of a circuit that keeps track
not only about the number of gates but
also about some additional parameters
okay so what what should be noted here
is that if you consider all previous
proofs of lower bounds which roughly 2
mm 2.5 m and 3 and they approved for
functions for which we know how to
compute them by circuits of size 6 M
each of them can be computed by a
circuit of size 6 M so among all these
proofs
only for the affiant dispersor we still
don't know whether it is possible to
compute it by a linear circuits by a
linear circuit or not so this is my
first open problem so is it possible to
show probably non constructively that
they exist an affine dispersal or for
sub linear dimension that has linear
circuit size okay let me let me also
mention another open problem so in and I
find this purser we do allow a find
substitutions and we would like our
function to be non constant after
sufficiently many affine substitutions
but we can go further and we we may
allow also to make quadratic
substitutions so what we recently shown
together with such a dilemma is that if
you construct a function which is non
constant so a function in NPO in some
larger class or even with some small
number of outputs with the following
property it is not constant on any
algebraic variety which is defined as a
set of common roots of say 2m
polynomials of degree two such that the
set is not so small so if it is not
constant for any such variety then for
such function we we have an improve is
slightly more improved lower bound it is
something like 3.1 n so it's still a
very tiny improvement but still so it is
better than the previous lower bound so
currently we do not know how to how to
construct such a function fine disperser
so if I'm not mistaken if you then the
construction by Benson and capacity has
circuit sized something like n cube so
why i've never written down this so i
just i just checked with some on the
paper but yeah so you should not take
this for granted
right so when I find this person he
still probably a candidate for for a
nonlinear lower bound okay so another so
in an issue with with with the gait
elimination proofs is the following when
proving say F would suppose you would
like to prove a poor M lower bound using
8 elimination so do this you do the
following you show that for any circuit
you may you can find a substitution that
removes 4 gates from this circuit so
while doing this you first need to go
through many cases of how the circuit
looks like but even when you remove 4
gates you need to go through all
possible sub cases when some two of
these 4 gates coincide and this gives
you many many many sub cases and this
makes all this gate elimination proves
very boring and tedious ok so this is
some informal explanation of why gate
elimination is probably not the method
for proving nonlinear lower bound but
there is also a formal explanation
so when proving a lower bound using a
gate elimination you basically show that
for any circuit you might you may find a
good substitution and recently we were
able to construct functions or circuits
for which no substitution of the form ax
replaced by any function of any or on
any other variables can remove more than
five gates from this circuit so
definitely if definitely if we would
like to prove a stronger than five and
lower bounds it is not enough to
construct some fancy new disperser for
example we need some new ideas we need
to extend the gate elimination method
somehow ok ok now let me let me proceed
to other approaches so one oh yeah yeah
so how big is the circuit so I guess we
can do this even for the linear size
seconds so so the construction of the of
the circuit yes so the second looks like
as follows so you take basically any any
function of any circuit on n variables
which probably depends essentially on
all of them and then you replace every
input of of this of the second with a
majority of three bits okay so and and
this is the basic construction so it is
not difficult to show that if you
replace any of these to be any of the
bits by by any as a function then you
can in a sense suppress this
substitution by by putting constants
here right and for this reason and the
size of this block is 5 oh this is my
hand waving so the circuit does it so it
might compute a disperser so if this
function is particularly difficult that
it computes a disperser probably of
dimension 2 n over 3 or something
right which is probably not that
interesting okay so for our multi output
functions so it is natural to ask
whether our lower bounds yet larger if
we are if we if we asked to compute
several outputs instead of instead of
instead of just one so it seems to be
more difficult of course but
unfortunately we do not know how to
prove this so if you can see the
functions with smaller of n outputs then
we do not know any any lower bound
stronger than that what I already
present it to you okay so we just do not
know how to exploit the fact that we
have many outputs but not just one so if
you allow for example for n outputs so
yeah for n outputs we can easily lift
any lower bound like 3 & 2 for M for
example and this is just because you
have you need M additional gates to
compute the outputs so this is the whole
argument okay but if we are talking
about small number of of outputs then we
still don't know how to use it so this
is this is an my other open problem that
try to prove for example 5 and lower
bound for an end-to-end function can
only increase
like the like if by a factor of two or
something like that
the constant because you can look at the
inner product with with a new new order
and new variables and make it a single
valued function
not sure baby
probably works in the in the arithmetic
setting but not in the boolean sorry
yeah at least it is not immediate for me
okay so let me also another another
probably natural question is are there
any other approaches for proving lower
bounds other than the gate elimination
and in fact I know just just two of them
and both of them can only prove to a
lower bound for some reason so the first
of them is is an old paper by Blum and
say some they what they proof is that if
you want to compute simultaneously the
disjunction and conjunction then then
the optimal way for doing this is just
compute them as two independent trees so
you have two trees of of n minus one
gate and what they do actually so the
first thing to note is that for for such
two functions you cannot proceed by gate
elimination because if you if you assign
a constant to any variable then you kill
immediately as a conjunction or
disjunction right so what they do
instead they they use an argument like
this so take a function if if it is take
a circuit I'm sorry if it is not two
independent trees then let's try to
reconstruct it a little bit and in the
end they arrived to two independent
trees of size n minus 1 okay so there is
the main idea is circuit reconstruction
so in other another proof was given by
checking in in a tea in 94 I'm sorry so
and here's a function which is which
which is considerate is is just a linear
function so a is a matrix so we multiply
and this is actually a parity check
matrix for for Hamming codes so this is
a matrix of size log n by n so for this
function what he shows is that in any
circuit which computes which computes
this function there should be at least n
gates of outdegree at least to than just
by counting the number of wires you get
you get the desired lower bound for both
of these proofs I here
no idea how to extend them to prove
something stronger than 2n so this is my
my next open problem so it would be nice
to come up with some non gait
elimination proof of some lower bound
stronger than 2m okay okay so the next
probably natural question is what can be
shown for symmetric functions so
symmetric functions are popular
candidates for for many other modules so
we we do know nonlinear lower bounds for
formulas we do know exponential over
bones form constant depth circuits at
the same time if we compute them by
seconds then it is not difficult to do
this in in size 5mm or even in size 4.5
mm okay so this in particular shows that
you know that some restricted models are
quite weak while this general secrets
are quite strong right so what is known
about symmetric functions is that for
many of them we do know a lower bound
2.5 m and for all of them we know an
upper bound 4.5 M and this has actually
done through the function which is
denote by denoted by some n which takes
and bits and outputs the logarithm of n
bits which represents binary in binary
some update and bits okay so there is a
small gap and well I still consider this
is an interesting problem to I mean to
at least reduce this gap so it would be
interesting to find to find exactly the
complexity of this function which is
probably one of the most basic symmetric
functions okay so the next the next
question is how we're proving lower
bounds is related to satisfiability
algorithms and this was this was
recently shown in but by williams that
by by improving circuit such algorithms
for souther all the wisdoms for a
particular for it
the second class you actually prove
circuit lower bounds okay so in this in
this direction it was proved by by
emmanuel and and to his coursers i'm
sorry i forgot the names that if you
improve if you come up with a
non-trivial algorithm for checking
satisfiability of circuits of size 2 cm
then actually you prove a lower bound
sein okay and this unfortunately does
not currently give us improved circuit
lower bounds because all that we know is
that is that we can check satisfiability
of circuits of size slightly less than
3m so in order to in order to get some
new lower bounds through this framework
we need to to design an algorithms that
check satisfiability of circuits of size
7m for example and unfortunately we do
not know how to do this and at the same
time so it's really open problem is of
course to improve this result but what
is probably more interesting is to show
that checking satisfiability of circuits
of size C and in some non-trivial time
imply C n circuit lower bounds okay so I
mean improving this result ok so the
next the next question so we do know
that most of the functions require
exponential circuits sighs so what about
the following approach let's take some
sufficiently large constant well for
example 24 we do know that there is a
circuit of size 100 for a fun that there
is a function I'm sorry of 20 bits that
requires circuits of size at least 100
so why not to try to cook a family of
functions out of this function ok so
let's let's fix such a function f and
let's define the function G as follows
so we just split the the input of size M
into chunks of size 20 and for each of
them
we apply the function f okay so for such
a function it is natural to expect that
an optimal circuit looks like this right
so so we have an over twenty independent
copies of variables for each of them we
need to apply our function f so it is
not adult Lee how like interchain like
mixing these circuits might help us so
it is natural to expect that such a
circuit would be would be optimal for
our function G and this would mean this
would give us a function of size of
circuit size 5m right at the same time
we have no idea how to prove this and in
moreover this is just not true for some
functions let me let me show you what is
known so the corresponding effect is
called mass production so we say that
this this effect occurs when computing
two copies of some function is can be
done by much smaller second than just by
computing by by combining two circuits
independently so what we do now is that
if the corresponding function G is very
simple then there is no mass production
effect so if you forget to complete
parities of M bits and of some other n
bits then the best thing that you can do
is to complete them independently at the
same time if we are talking not about
such simple function as parity but about
a function which has very high circuit
complexity then it is actually known
that computing it twice is almost the
same as computing it once it was proven
by you click many years ago okay okay so
and it seems to be that we do not know
much about this mass production effects
how this is my my next open problem so
it would be interesting to understand
it's a little bit more about the
functions avoiding the mass production
effect
makes expect support oh yeah so it is
not avoiding the mass production effect
yeah and I would like a function some
probably simple function which avoids it
[Music]
if I pronounced it correctly is that if
you look at the optimal construction of
circuit for heart function you end up
like computing every function on a small
number of it yeah then you can sort of
reuse that yeah exactly exactly yeah
just assited a bit more like I mean
really that that works like you can
rephrase Russell's comment to saying
like if incentive to there you put like
a constant T exactly so as soon as T is
small of two to the M divided by M even
more right yes why I just simplified the
result here but what he actually proved
you're right is that for much larger
values of T okay so I let me then
proceed to get to the last this last to
the last section as a natural question
is okay so we would like to prove in
only a super linear lower bound and so
does it help if we reduce the depth of
this circuit to be logarithmic we cannot
ask it to be smaller than logarithmic of
course but what if we restrict the depth
to be logarithmic unfortunately even in
this setting we do not know how to show
this and but of course we do know that
if we restrict there as adapts to be
constant then we do now even exponential
our bounds and there is a well known
result bivalent it should be probably
within seventy seven which says that if
you prove a strong enough lower bound
for depth three circuit depth three
seconds in particular you would like to
find a function which cannot be computed
by an
of that many CNF said that each CNF has
it more square with n variables in every
clause so if you construct such a
function then you get a nonlinear lower
bound for a function in the setting
where the secretary is requested to to
have a logarithmic depth okay so
currently of course we do not know how
to do this well this is kind of an
obvious open problem so this is the best
we can we can prove right now roughly 2
to the square root of M I'm into this
depth 3 second but this is an obvious
open problem let me probably show you
one more
less obvious open problem so what we do
know for for depth three circuit
slightly better lower bounds are known
for their for the case where we can see
the war of KC and apps where K is a
constant so in this in this setting
assume that K is a constant okay in this
case we we can prove lower bounds 2 to
the N over K so this is a result by
petula put looking and they moreover
buttery sucks and then three years ago
prove that for k equal to 2 it is even
possible to prove well in a sense an
optimal lower bound to to the M okay so
so now the question is whether we can
use this actually non-trivial results to
get something for unrestricted circuits
in particular yes this is the same the
same result by Valiant that let me
phrase it as follows so we have a
circuit of size n and m depth log n then
it is possible to transform it into the
following depths three circuits so this
isn't more of that many CN apps such
that each tnf has get more square with
variables in every clause okay so what
we can show is like as the counterpart
is the following so if you have a
circuit of sizes and no matter what is
the depth of this circuit we can
transform it into in
the EPS tree formula with the following
parameters here we have a constant which
constant is not at all important at this
point and here we have size two to the s
divided by two point five okay so this
is like a nice counterpart which does
not give any new lower bounds but still
I mean it is interesting whether it
holds in general whether we can whether
we can transform any any small enough
circuit into some non-trivial depth
three formula okay and this is this is
my last question so for example it would
be nice if we can prove that any circuit
of Saia with with as gates can be
transformed into a depth 3 formula with
with this parameters so it is 2 to the s
2 to the s over 4 to CMS so if we if we
can do this then just by plugging in the
result by a to resections n we get a
lower bound for M yeah and this is mm
yeah okay I forgot about this this
extension of this question so what
generally it would be interesting to
check whether any linear size any linear
size circuit can be transformed into
some non-trivial into some non-trivial
depth 3 formula by non trivial I mean
that it has size smaller than 2 to the N
here and it has some constant size CNF
here ok yeah and this is finally it and
this is just some summary of all of all
the lower bounds of all the open
questions
[Applause]
so the Padres exact same function
computer but it doesn't it's just for
that our opponents any projection this
per serving
[Applause]